[Music]  um  running away  [Music]  i think that we're finally ready to to  be a community that doesn't  telegraph through our public art that we  are  pretty fine with white supremacy  are we  [Music]  to the young people out there i hope  that this empowers you  to speak up on the issues that matter  and to take charge in your own cities  and communities  no platform for white supremacy no  platform race for racism  and no platform for hate  [Music]  according to the southern poverty law  center hundreds of symbols of the  confederacy  remain in place across the u.s even as  the fight continues to remove them  states like alabama mississippi and  tennessee are enacting policies  to protect them  you